looking at this starting all right we're
live welcome everybody another YouTube
hangout really excited to be here uh
this is a little bit of a twist so
initially this was supposed to be an
interview with somebody's writing a blog
post but I don't know what happened he
didn't show up so instead I pulled in
there's a lot of you guys watch her
asking questions I decided that would I
would pull in yeah buzzes when it starts
I would pull in Alex I an SI hey how's
it going Alex I works at Toronto thats
all say he's in charge of operations the
company that I've invested in and we're
going to talk about our ideas on how to
be successful and you have comments
questions you can leave it in the chat
box on the side and we'll get to them so
let's kick it off Alex yeah strategy
strategy for entrepreneurs to be
successful um I think that for me at
least what I found was really about to
them hi guys my first time doing this
hot virgin yeah I hate hangovers and
thank you for that comment okay so the
main strategy is um focusing always on
the the bigger picture because you will
tend to have a lot of distractions in
your daily life whether it's emails
personal matters everything and
sometimes that can be a little bit
overwhelming so you need to keep
focusing on that that big picture to
develop it right I like inside I like it
for me uh you guys for those of you
watch my channel ongoing you know it's
about the passion you gotta love what
you're doing you got to wake up
everything be excited what you're going
to do right I wake up today excited that
it's hang out thursday get the hang with
some friends get to answer your
questions right like you got to wake up
and be excited with what you're doing
and in the titans like the bigger
picture like what you're trying to build
right here's the big thing here's my big
idea what i'm trying to build that
doesn't excite you then you gotta go
find something else to do a lot of
people jump into opportunities just
because they're going to make a lot of
money and that almost never works out
because you're not willing to stick with
it and drive through all like the the
hard times that are involved running a
business
um so let's get to the questions you've
already got a couple coming in Kane what
are the strategies there what are the
strategies there has moved that have
moved the needle for both of you in
terms of success what's the strategy
that has moved the needle for you in
your success with trying to dance salsa
what's the strategy when I come back and
fight oh sorry I yeah I got it so what's
the strategy has movement of the needle
to success in terms of my success yeah
um you know what it's it's funny enough
it's letting myself be open to criticism
um it's it's it's always a humbling
experience and I you know every time I
think that I have something or
understand something I have
conversations with people who are within
that industry my colleagues are you and
you know putting letting myself be
challenged and accepting that what not
the other day I agree or not isn't
important because it's important it's
important for growth I disagree with my
comment yeah uh you know I would say the
thing that helped me the most is
building a team you know uh you can only
do so much yourself so in my business
now I've got 16 people and I was able to
ramp up so much once I started bringing
on a team you look at the youtube
channel i started out doing all myself
and I could do one video a week because
it took me a long time to figure was
going to write and research it and then
find the pictures and then set up the
camera and then record it and then edit
it and then like this a lot of work to
put up a video I now built a team and
there's five of us who were just on the
YouTube channel and now we can do three
videos a day right and so recognizing
what you're really good at recognizing
what you suck at and then building a
team to help compensate for your
witnesses and let you focus more of your
time on the things that make you come
alive that's awesome it's good yeah how
do you like that yeah all or nothing how
would you suggest for me to gain
exposure I've been working on my channel
website in a niche industry for eight
months and received positive feedback
from my follower
but I want more reach how do I get more
reach more exposure what you think oh
Jesus is a little bit this is a little
bit of out of my comfort zone do you
want to start off and maybe I could add
something to it maybe you missed sure
man is jabbing you there and maybe I
missed ah listen first of all I totally
get it totally understand I want more
reach right like you know I think as an
entrepreneur constantly searching for
more you're constantly striving they hit
more uh you know I look at my channel on
my youtube channel people say oh you got
130 thousand subscribers I feel like
that's nothing like I feel like I should
be the million subscribers plus I want
to get there and then more and then
beyond right I want to impact millions
of people that's the goal and so what I
find helps in terms of like practical
execution one consistency right being
consistent regular content if you have a
youtube channel you know whatever it is
once a week three times a week every day
consistent consistent consistent
consistent keep it on a regular schedule
ideally even like the times of the day
any of the new things that I've started
the Twitter chats for example right the
second Thursday every month 1230pm
people get used to coming back and
coming back and coming back so one
consistency to you gotta provided an
amazing experience give them amazing
value right they come for the first time
do they love it right do they want to
come back do they want to tell their
friends I remember the first uh speaking
gig I did you know I sold my business
nobody knew who I was and I started
helping entrepreneurs I couldn't attract
anybody because nobody knew who I was so
the first gig that I had to speak was at
a YMCA it was free three people came out
to it three people to a free thing I not
it like immediately this is a challenge
you have expectations right you see all
these other people getting huge
audiences and lots of people commenting
and people coming out to their events
and then you do yours and it sucks right
it flops not because you suck just you
haven't had to reach yet you haven't had
the experience yet and so it was a big
letdown like my heart sank when I saw
the only three people showed up to my
free event right but that's that's
that's what happens you see you feel
like you put a lot of energy and effort
and value out there and people aren't
recognizing it yet and so you're being
consistent but then making sure that the
people who do come get an amazing
experience so those two people who
showed up they changed you know they
became different people when they left
right I spent a lot of time helping them
out focusing on them helping them with
their challenges and they walked out
different people than what they walked
in as and that's great because the next
time I had an event guess what those two
people came back they would invite their
friends word of mouth started to spread
it ended up being that later the next
year when I was doing the events over
and over every week did another one uh I
took over chapters which is our like
barnes and nobles in canada and i had a
free event there and it was the second
most popular event at the chapters that
year second to sting so sting was number
one and I was number two and I started
from nothing started from nobody knowing
my name started from three people
showing up to a free event and just
building and building and building so
everybody that comes you give them
appreciation you give them recognition
you give them lots of value so they want
to come back the next time the next time
the next time that's what I got that's
uh when you got it you know what I miss
ya you missed anything about them I
think that really it's important to
whatever your niche market is it's
important to support all the other
people that are within that industry
giving your time and your expertise to
help others so I mean comparison I
Toronto dance salsa salsa school so if
someone is running an event to raise
money for cancer society you know
offering them you know what pro bono
we're gonna come we're gonna teach
people we're gonna help you raise money
things that will help the community cuz
people love that it's important for
people and it makes your brand it makes
you grow and be more appreciated by a
larger audience it's not just focusing
on yourself but focusing on the bigger
community and how you can affect it yeah
it's a jump off that point you can
leverage their audiences to write if you
are no name you could partner up
with a local charity or local business
and they can help promote it too if
you're doing it with somebody else
they're sending their lists and then the
next time you do in the venue can say
all we did their last one with you know
name drop and that can help build your
credibility and get the momentum going
faster thank you for making this channel
by the way i watch your videos every day
has made such a difference I appreciate
that that's why I do it it's not a
question but we do recognize okay you
gotta recognize come on all of nothing's
my time writing that man you gotta show
some appreciation key to all enough
there's no matter matter we're gonna
heat is getting money yeah right side
Salvador how can you grow a clothing
brand and what is the process of getting
your product into zoom your any big
azumi as or any big store clothing brand
get into a big store okay you know what
this is a little bit of a segue I used
to I used to do sales and I used to sell
a specific I used to sell debit machines
and whether it was a convenience or
worked into our factory of 1,500 people
I sold to businesses and corporations
that some of my employees were surprised
that i could get in and i think it is
actually let like work a lot of it is
knowing where you want to be who the
important people are and going at least
in my personal going to meet them and
making that first impression i think
that sometimes people are disconnected
by assuming that if you send an email or
you you do something indirectly that it
will affect that I think people are in
my mind are undervaluing connection sure
like I'm sorry under validating Salvador
yes sorry yes under valley connection
and you know it's that firm handshake as
you go to meet whoever would be in
charge of that store and just
introducing yourself and showing value
in person I don't know yeah to tag on
that i would i would think about what
you're really good at and then how you
can leverage those strengths to get the
goal that you're after so you know alex
is grated sales is great at talking to
people he's you know grated working his
way in he can open up doors and other
people may not because that's his skill
set and so that can work right like you
can go and start trying to set up
meetings following up doing
a personal a lot of these companies will
offer have days where you can do meet
the buyers and pitch them right I
remember even for Toronto and salsa we
got on the shopping channel like QVC
here in Canada and they had a day they
had a day where they had other buyers
and they invited people to come you had
to send a pitch to them and then you
show up and you have 10 minutes with the
buyer and you talk about what you're
doing and then they say yes or no and we
were prepared and we had the business
case worked out and so they said yes and
we were able to get on on the channel so
you can look out for when companies are
having these days to talk to potential
buyers you can look at when their buyers
might be speaking in different events
you can follow the buyers on twitter if
they're on their engage with them on
social media that's like the sales route
the other route that you might be able
to take is more the the branding the
marketing the kicking up a noise to give
yourself some kind of position of
strength before going to them and that
would be execution right so if you are
out there getting a lot of marketing in
the marketplace that people are talking
about your clothes that people are
wearing your t-shirts if people are
there's a lot of buzz around it then you
can how the brand's come to you right
the clothing companies will come to you
and say hey we want to represent you we
want you to be in our store and so that
puts you in a much more position of
power because now instead of you knock
on their door they're coming to you and
wanted to make some kind of deal but
again just leverage what you're good at
if you're great at sales and go and make
some sales if you're great at marking
then go and market your product um
either way you got to put in the hustle
to get the results Salvador's good
answer next uniquely Shannon designs
just curious I know it's different for
everybody but how long would you say it
took you to build a decent audience and
really start seeing the consistent
success this is for you yeah maybe um
this is a great question I think I
struggled uh I struggled for a couple
years years like slow growth and like a
couple hundred views on the video and a
few comments um and it wasn't really
until two things 1i invested morn myself
you know if you look back on my
videos on the YouTube channel the
content is the same like I'm still
talking about successful entrepreneurs
helping other entrepreneurs leveraging
and modeling what other people are doing
the content is still really good my
delivery is just way better the
execution is way better look as you do
anything more you'll get better right
I'm Way better on camera than I was
before right this is Alex's first time
here on the channel you know he's doing
ok so next time he'll do it better and i
just got a job back I know thank you um
so uh the two things that kind of helped
really change one is when i got my agent
uh i got assigned a trainer and i got a
media trainer and every week i have a
call with her for for just over a year
every we got a call we dissected my
videos and she made me better on camera
she made me better as a presenter as a
speaker and then to was building up my
team and going from one video week two
to one a day to then to add a two then
three a day now and so you look back on
my channel is like 34 years of slow and
then it just started taking off right
even now I'm I have a hundred thirty
thousand subscribers almost and we're
growing at 20,000 subscribers a month
well which is pretty insane growth um
channels that my size should not be
growing that quickly which is good I
mean I want to grow faster I still don't
feel like it's enough I feel like gotta
impact lon entrepreneurs and explode but
so I don't think it's a matter of time I
don't think it's really the like you can
model what I did and then also have to
take three four years to get there I
think it's more about doing maybe what I
didn't do I was consistent but I wasn't
self examining enough to figure out how
I could be doing better and how I could
be a better speaker better presenter
have more powerful points and so you can
do that you can crunch down the timeline
a lot faster than how long it took me
what are your thoughts on university oh
I helicase if you give an answer for
that
uh I don't know I didn't audio no not
yet not yet other words gonna look up
Alex I an announcer following the
leverage that I'm delivered to you good
and take some of your fault okies all
right well that's interesting because
that's how it works right I was just on
a blog earlier today and people who are
following the co-hosts now we're
following me right like if you make
guest appearances in other people's
channels and then like what you have to
say like if Alex at a YouTube channel
you like his wisdom you're gonna go
check him out you're going to subscribe
right so those collaborations and really
amp up the success yeah okay ona um so
spider spider 95 thoughts on University
what are your thoughts on yours um I i
saw i studied psychology i originally
wanted to be a couple therapist that was
my original goal yeah marriage
counseling I'm I have to say in spite of
the fact that I didn't follow you know
my original goal I don't regret going
into sorry I have to look there right I
don't regret um going to university it
really taught me how to think you know
you can buy books you can tech text
books you can read I met a lot of
amazing people i started the first
university club in that at York
University where I studied for chinese
chess iran that for five years i was an
enriching experience helped me be where
I am right now so if you're I guess
maybe the question is whether you need
to go to university to be an
entrepreneur probably along those lines
maybe um I I think that really it's yes
and no I mean it depends on I mean
you're in a clear example you were in
University yeah started a company you
you know struggling you grew it and made
something incredible red and then you
piggyback off of that for something for
something for something bigger when I'm
talking to you I ok I need to get used
to this anyway so I'm for me personally
it was worth it to go to university I
would never not do the same way that I
did with all the faults and all the
great things that have happened no yeah
this is a tough one for me um watchu
coming up with a video soon in the
channel talking about education and
different entrepreneurs views on it ah
I think I think honestly it's so if your
goal is to be an entrepreneur I think
the content is pretty weak in university
I think it's hard to go to university to
want to be an entrepreneur I think what
it gives you is a fantastic back-up plan
I think a lot of entrepreneurs or want
to be entrepreneurs try to be an
entrepreneur and then realize it's not
for them and then have nothing to fall
back on and if all you have is a high
school education that can really hurt
you and getting the job market I think
nobody cares for the most part what your
degree is in in the business world there
are some fields where they they would
like if you're if you are trying to be a
doctor and you don't you haven't gone to
school to be a doctor it's a little
awkward it has a little awkward and it's
locked in but for the most part like
nobody asked me about my degree uh if I
i watched university of toronto i have
an undergrad bachelor of commerce and
finance but nobody would care if I just
had a high school education or if I had
a PhD doesn't really make a difference
actually interesting funny side story
when I was in the venture capital world
if somebody had a PhD that was on the
management team or was the founder it'd
almost be a strike against because the
thinking would be they'd be to book
smart and not street smart enough mom
and so if you walk in with a business
plan and your PhD uh it's a strike
against you in terms of getting venture
capital which was interesting um so the
content i found not that helpful again
fourth-year university class at
university of toronto really
well-respected university uh i already
knew all the stuff on entrepreneurship
like i was really running my business
like it was a it was a it was almost a
joke the content and none of the other
content really helped me that much in
terms of my university in terms of my
business career sire like the economics
none of the courses really had a big
impact on me as an entrepreneur um i
think the biggest value is probably in
the connections in the meeting people
obviously my business partners who then
i launched the business if I could do it
all over again I don't know I
Hollywood still go to university I think
it's just my upbringing and and I knew
had the back-up plan like if it doesn't
work out you can go you can always go
get a job and you have the degree those
are my thoughts and we're going to share
some some thoughts later on probably
next weekend I think because there's a
lot of people who are like very against
university education think it's a total
waste of money and others who are on
side so I'll let you listen to their
advice too and you can decide what works
for you a cute comber cucumber I like
the name cucumber is it worth seeking
investors in another country we live in
Sweden and we're working on something
that will change internet advertising
but we really want to go overseas should
we do it um this is a little bit over my
head but I guess I'll just answer it
with the question ah do you need
investors in other countries to go
overseas in the first place is Sweden
not a place where you can get investors
and then bring that out like a de
sumption that Union investors in North
America to bring the thing to north of
it sorry the thing to bring your idea to
North America um I don't know if that
necessarily right clicks together right
plus it's a bigger gamble if you go to
another country and you try to find
investors there I don't know I I feel
safer working with people in Canada and
expanding somewhere else versus trying
to find investors okay so that's just my
perspective I don't know yeah it's hard
it's really hard it's hard to get it's
hard to get investment capital period
let alone another country especially
early stage investors angel investors
want to be able to drive their car and
see you if something went wrong right
like if everything's going well great
but it doesn't always go well it almost
never always goes well and angels if you
look at where angels invest it's always
within a geographic range of where they
live and it's usually see my monitor
usually within driving distance right
you'd have to be so stellar amazing for
somebody to want to hop on a plane to
come and see you and
going to do you like not even close
you're over in Sweden right so totally
different mindset you know it's hard
enough for Canadians we have a physical
board that you can drive across it's
hard enough for Canadians in Toronto to
get investors from New York which is
only it's an hour-and-a-half flight uh
it's hard it's really challenging where
if you want to get that investment
dollars you really have to be in that
market so I also don't see a lot of
angels wanted to invest in a Swedish
company and you spend so much of your
time fundraising instead of actually
executing and running your business that
it will likely hold you back so I'd be
looking at locals I'd be looking at if
you're doing an online campaign of some
kind if you're doing a Kickstarter or
any of the online angel campaigns I'd be
really worried about the angel one's own
because you want to screen the people
who come in or or try to boot strap it
to a certain point so you show momentum
like if you have momentum you're gaining
traction it's way easier to get the
investment money you need then if you're
a pure startup and you just have a
concept mm-hmm a plan a means you
already gave up on plan no a plan B got
rid of me I a I read that twice it a
plan B means you this from job Bordeaux
a plan B means you already give up on
plan a it's a BS answer for an
entrepreneur plan beads did we talk
about plan B which is all university I
think he's referring to you always an
option yeah yeah that's interesting um
yeah I don't know I you go win the
things you know I'm all about exploring
right I like to explore and I don't know
when things are gonna work out and when
they're not gonna work out um I know now
about myself that I would be miserable
in a corporate job I'll be museum a
corporate job uh that's from some
exposure to summer jobs and just see my
friends struggling and dealing with some
companies that even I have his clients
mm-hmm and I'm like man I would not want
their job um but I have the I have the
experience now to know that we're
when I was how old are you go to
university 18 19 yeah I didn't have that
I didn't even think I wanted to be an
entrepreneur at that point isn't how the
environment around me so what I I'm not
that I'm not to burn the boats guy you
know what's his name Perez was a Perez I
forget that the Spanish explorer who
went to Mexico to take over Mexico to
conquer Mexico and he sunk all his boats
to say basically we are gonna we're
gonna win this fight or we're gonna die
there's no retreat and there's a lot of
people who take that mentality that's
not me you know I think it's okay to
have a full-time job and start your
business on the side and not quit
because too many people the downside of
that strategy is like the upside is you
win the downside is you die right and
that's what happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs they go all in they quit
their jobs they use up the three months
of savings that they have and then
they're stuck with nothing they burn
their bridges they can't go back and get
that other job they had so they're
begging trying to get any kind of job to
survive and so I'm much more of that
school of thought where do a part-time
make some money continue to learn work
at a job where you're getting an
education not just a paycheck and then
when you reach the point where your
business can support you and build
yourself up you know not not make tons
of money but pay the rent you know put
food on the table when your business and
get there that's when you go full time
and so um yeah there's two schools of
thoughts there's that there's a nope
there's no plan B that's it we're only
going plan a plan a or die ah where I
don't think that way so what do you
think um you know what it's it's a weird
comparison that I would make but if you
were to park your car on an uphill slope
you know it's choosing whether to put
the parking brake on or not right you
can say well one break is enough I put
the parking brake on I don't know it's
like it's it's just it's security why
not if I had I fight it's long as okay
so I think maybe the thing is that if
your plan B doesn't take away from your
plan a in a lot of ways then it's fine
like if you're not sabotaging your
planning for Plan B but it's like
you said hindsight 20 20 how did you
know like you said oh sorry Joe Joe so
Joe Joe is it Joe is calling you a [ __ ]
he right now plan B is her [ __ ] so you
got it you got you it's all right thank
you thank you Joe for that comment um if
heís you know hindsight if it was 20 20
right i mean if you look at Evan he
couldn't have known going into
University that he'd be an entrepreneur
that he would get to where he is right
now so I having safety and security is
not a bad thing I mean I don't write it
doesn't have to be you don't have to be
you don't have to be living in an
extreme kind of environment to succeed
right that kind of write gold for a 30
kilometre hike with a single granola bar
kind of thing right it's you know I
think it depends on your personality to
be honest I think some people uh there's
a lot of people who if they do something
on on the side and they don't they don't
burn the bridges they won't do it they
don't they're never they don't have the
drive enough they have to think it's a
comment where is it the vision and where
I want to go and and I can I can do
something on the side and be excited by
that and build it into something because
this YouTube channel right I'm all-in on
YouTube right now I'm all-in on YouTube
right it's like the I get a lot of my
joy from you guys on YouTube but when I
started it was on the side right it was
a one it was a part-time thing that I
did by myself I had my successful
business that I didn't touch and this
was Evan strange scientific weird
project that he was going off on and I
try a lot of those things and most of
them don't work out you know I lose
interest it's usually what it is i'll
try something guys it's not for me i
could have said screw everything else
I'm going all in on YouTube that's it
fire everybody at my company close down
shop and just go all in on YouTube and
that may have worked but it may also
backfire right maybe three might say no
like ah I don't like you too you know I
don't like having to prepare I don't
like this schedule that have to get used
to write and then I'm screwed because I
left everything else behind and so the
point is uh I don't have the knowledge
to know that like that's where I want to
be like this is what's going to work out
and I love doing small experiments I
so it depends on your personality I'm
not that all or nothing guy and if you
need that to stay motivated to force you
to get out of bed and do something then
great do it and there's a lot of people
who are like that or if you can continue
to work on your goal and move forward
every day and keep progress even if it's
half an hour a day an hour a day then
take that route it's my advice good
hopefully you can stop la you know
throwing the this is out though man yeah
mine Joe little respect here is believed
nation I can't get a job could I have
this is this is Ali I can't get a job
could I have dream to start me on
business what should i do thank you for
your help so I can't get a job I have a
dream start my own business what can I
do can't get a job have a dream start
your own business what can he do what
Kennelly dude ah I think the first thing
is you do need to have a job of some
kind um I came to this country when I
was 9 my mom came she had no English she
was a judge back home she started from
scratch here working in factories with
no English to support me um you know
she's leaps and bounds since then where
she is now um so I have to say you do I
mean you have to sometimes put your
pride aside you whatever you can so that
you know there's food on the table your
basic necessities are met and then from
there you think about your strengths you
think about where you can where you can
um where you can grow what you can
contribute right um it's not just about
I think starting up a store of some kind
and that's it your business owner and
they will succeed on its own right I
don't know Joe's running back thanks
believe nation means no plan B Joe
Bordeaux listen bordeaux nation means no
planet be jealous more donation that
believe nation okay um no but I
appreciate the band's here it's fine um
yeah yeah i agree i would say i would
say get a job to learn right whatever
business you're thinking about starting
up before you do it go get a job to
learn about it so i would ideally you
know the company that I want to start is
a shoe company right I would I wouldn't
go work for Nike cuz you
going to get some crappy job I would go
work for a 10-person shoe company where
you can get close to the CEO founder
learn from them sponge off of their
wisdom and then you're more prepared to
go out and launch your own business
because if you go and do it yourself
you're probably going to blow a ton of
money make a lot of mistakes this way
you're getting paid to make mistakes
right you're getting paid to make
mistakes you're getting paid to make
connections you want to get as close to
that founder as possible alex is lacking
something probably Bordeaux Buddha
Bordeaux Bordeaux say he provides the
entertainment um learn as much as you
can and you stop when again you can
start your business and make enough
money from that and when you stop
learning like if you stop learning at
your job you should go either start your
own business if you're ready or find
another job where you're going to learn
more from hmm spiro 95 number one book
that's influenced you the most um how to
win friends and influence people psych
psych major right there ya know I wager
you know what it's all about positive
psychology it's all about showing
appreciation and giving value and giving
high expectations to people and you know
they will go out of their way to meet
them it's it was that it was that really
big eye-opener it changed dramatically
how I interact with people with my
family with my girlfriend with everybody
in my life and about just being genuine
about your needs and caring about other
people's needs and being surprised at
how far they will go for you that's yeah
I like four hour work week Tim Ferriss i
cain't i'm probably the most popular
book for entrepreneurs number one New
York Times bestseller for Robin how many
years um I don't like the idea of just
hey let's do this business on the juice
to make money that's one of the concept
is mused but what what helped me with
that is is time management and
delegating right like building a team
and delegating because that that book
came out a right time for me where I was
doing too much myself and I needed to
outsource a lot of stuff and even just
recognizing that I could hire somebody
that doesn't have to be full-time
doesn't have to be in you know with me
where was at home
uh and that they could work the help bro
my company that changed how I operated
and so I'm a big fan of that how
important is reading scuba steve how
burnt extremely important how often you
take time to read um I'd say about two
times a week actually yeah ah how long
two times a week comes what oh like how
many hours yeah I'd say maybe words are
we are we talking about we're not
talking about tech like psychology
articles news we just talked about books
if we're talking about books probably
said reading reading oh I mean general
oh my god I don't know more than that
way more than that probably uh 16 to 20
hours a week maybe which doesn't seem
like much actually when I said out loud
I should be reading more that's why our
time job man yeah that's that's quite
quite a bit like over this like I
consume a large amount of knowledge um
and it's extremely important it expends
my vocabulary for one thing and it just
helps expand my thinking and I read
everything psychology technology science
everything basically that I can get my
hands on that's it's interesting for me
what about you uh I have shifted my
consumption over the years it used to be
I used to be a lot of books tons of book
anything especially around famous
entrepreneur bios i read an insane
amount of that I've shifted more
recently to be more video uh I've
consumed a lot of YouTube videos how
to's especially the things I'm trying to
learn so like when I was learning how to
build my youtube channel like watch all
of Tim Schmoyer and their leaves us
stuff to gain the knowledge um I read
very few books nowadays the stuff that
I'll read are more blogs i subscribe to
news keyword searches that i'm
subscribed to i tend to be very narrow
and focused so i'll know a lot about a
few things and nothing about most
everything else you want to ask me about
baseball league of legends salsa I have
a depth of knowledge that
that is pretty insane but you asking
about other stuff world events politics
I have no idea um and that's that's just
me alex is crackin yo and you know ah
what else you can't believe and not go
all in Joe Bordeaux Joe I said so that's
an interesting statement and um what I
believe in going all laying on is
yourself I go all in on myself I don't
necessarily non an idea because I don't
know how that's going to work out right
so I believe in myself and my confidence
so then what I'm doing if I'm going out
and speak onstage or I'm doing camera
videos for you guys I'm trying new
projects I will give it my best until my
passion runs out for but to know in
advance where your passion will fizzle
is impossible and that's a challenge
because you could say I'm going to go
all in on what's my next project I'm
going to go all in on being an arborist
and I love trees so I'm gonna go all in
and being an artist and then you start
doing it and and you lose the passion
how many jobs have you tried that you
thought would be cool and then sucked
when you got into it how many books have
you started reading that you thought
would be fun and interesting and then
you stopped halfway through it right
there's been lots of things that you've
tried and failed that right I i tried
rock climbing and I hated it first day I
hated it you know I tried snowboarding
and I loved and became obsessed with it
and would push meetings to go
snowboarding and would be answering
emails on the on the chairlift from
Syrians and then and then my passion
dipped right and I stopped loving it so
I stopped doing it's all sad love for
10-plus years I'm still doing it ah it's
impossible to know you can't connect the
dots looking forward you can only
connect the dots looking backwards and
so to go all in on something where you
don't know if your passion is going to
be there or not to me doesn't make sense
but I go all in on myself knowing that
if that doesn't going to
that doesn't work I have something else
that I'm doing at something else that
I'm doing something else Angela
constantly experimenting we got lots of
questions we got it we got to wrap up
where we're going over time last
question what's the last question is
Alex Armenian is Arman Arman is Alex
Alex Alex replacement yeah it's Alex
Armenian I am Armenian yes this I don't
know if you guessed that by my last name
but so we're like a lot of things when
your question there okay fine lass who
receive oh my gosh i love league of
legends look me up believe team on the
North American server oh my god no I'm
sorry I'm not judging huh believe team
on the North American server hook me up
we will get a game going thank you guys
for watching round of applause for Alex
did a good job thank you thanks guys
we'll talk to you soon